foreign
[Music]
Millennials hey Jax how you doing I'm
doing good excited to be back with my
girly girl it is time for the fast five
stories that you need to know happy
straw day from Jackson Claude and Raz
and stress that's us literally
anti-heroes
if you watch a show like you have taste
you have style you're funny you're
interesting you're beautiful stunning
and smart
me yeah hi we talk about pop culture but
we really just talk about ourselves the
podcast podcast meetings meetings
meetings
so excited to be back in studio with you
doing our thing fabulous fabulous
fabulous fabulous hump day here in New
York Friday strategy welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome so we're just like
kind of like mobiles
[Music]